Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Vous aussi vous aimez faire la cuisine ?
Ça tombe bien.
Imaginez, vous êtes une très bonne
cuisinière, un très bon cuisinier.
Vous avez un restaurant étoilé
et vous allez créer
le nouveau plat du soir.
Est-ce que vous préférez faire
votre nouvelle création
avec ces très beaux raviolis
d’une excellente qualité industrielle
ou est-ce que vous préféreriez
faire votre création
avec ces ingrédients que vous trouvez
en vrac et que vous avez pu choisir ?
Maintenant, vous avez
le rêve de créer une montre.
Pour cela, vous devenez
horlogère ou horloger.
Certains le sont déjà.
Pour faire votre montre ou surtout
pour faire votre mouvement,
vous allez choisir les ingrédients en
vrac, c’est-à-dire les composants en vrac.
Mais il y a un problème : en horlogerie,
il n’y a pas de magasin de vrac.
D’un côté, vous trouvez
de très bons mouvements industriels
qui sont en parfait état de marche
et qu’il ne faut surtout pas toucher.
De l’autre côté, vous trouverez
des artisans horlogers
qui font tous les composants eux-mêmes
et dont la montre coûte au final
le prix d’une voiture de sport,
si ce n’est celui d’une maison.
De là, vous allez vous poser la question :
« Comment je peux faire ma propre montre,
mon propre mouvement,
en me situant entre ces deux extrêmes ? »
La réponse, c’est : openmovement.
Je vais vous dire pourquoi je vous
en parle ce soir à La Chaux de Fonds.
Et pour cela, je tourne
le temps un peu en arrière.
Attention.
Voici Roman - un autre temps -
qui part en 1992 à la Vallée
de Joux pour travailler.
Ce choix est motivé par le fait
qu’il m’était impossible
d’apprendre le français à l’école,
Mais j’étais possédé
par l’idée d’y parvenir.
Et aussi par l'idée de faire une formation
supplémentaire un peu plus tard
en français à La Chaux de Fonds.
Avec quelques mots en poche et deux années
plus tard, j’arrive à La Chaux de Fonds
pour faire la formation de technicien
en restauration d’horlogerie ancienne -
d’ailleurs ici dans les ateliers du musée.
Et à ce moment-là, je me suis
rendu compte d’une chose.
Je me suis rendu compte que La Chaux
de Fonds était une ville particulière.
Froide d'apparence, mais chaleureuse.
Il est facile d’entrer
en contact avec les gens,
même pour un Suisse allemand comme moi.
Ça m’a beaucoup plu et j’y suis resté.
Après deux années de formation
et après dix ans dans les ateliers
de restauration d’horlogerie ancienne
chez Parmigiani à Fleurier,
je me suis mis à mon compte en 2007.
À ce moment-là, je me suis rendu
compte d’une autre chose.
Jusque-là, il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ont partagé leur savoir-faire avec moi :
pendant l’apprentissage à la Vallée de
Joux, au Tech à La Chaux de Fonds,
des artisans du musée,
tous ces gens chez Parmigiani
et encore bien d’autres.
Et je suis venu à la question
que vous vous êtes posée avant :
comment est-il possible de se faire
sa propre montre avec son propre mouvement
tout en restant abordable ?
J’étais face à des raviolis
et un rayon de vrac complètement vide.
De là sont nées deux idées.
La première,
celle de faire ma propre montre
avec un excellent mouvement industriel.
Et la deuxième,
celle de faire un mouvement partagé.
En parlant de ce mouvement partagé
à trois amis horlogers,
cela les a enflammés
et nous avons créé l’association
openmovement en 2009.
Le but était de construire un mouvement
dont les fichiers 3D et les plans
seraient librement accessibles.
Avec, à la clé, un kit de composants bruts
qui donne finalement accès aux composants,
à l’image d’un magasin de vrac.
Aujourd’hui, ce mouvement est en train
de passer de la réalité virtuelle
à la réalité réelle.
Mais il fallait quoi
pour arriver jusqu’ici ?
Il fallait quoi pour arriver jusqu’ici ?
En 2009 - (Rit.)
En 2009, on a commencé.
Oui, on l’a fait il y a longtemps.
Ça fait quatorze ans.
Ça fait longtemps, hein ?
Vous avez fait quoi il y a quatorze ans ?
C'est presque un cinquième d'une vie.
Nous, on a fignolé
dix des techniques de mouvement.
Ça, c’était lors d’une soirée appelée
« Soirée secrets des régleurs ».
C’était avec ces gens,
tous des spécialistes
et des passionnés de l’horlogerie.
Après -
Oups.
Je suis perturbé, ça devait être noir.
Après ça, on a cherché comment
financer le développement.
Alors -
Je suis perdu, pardon.
Pour commander -
Comment financer le développement ?
C’est un passage difficile en fait.
On a cherché -
On nous a proposé de l’aide
pour chercher du financement.
On a accepté cette aide.
Mais au lieu de trouver les financements,
on a trouvé des ennuis.
En fait, on était confronté
à un gros conflit d’intérêts
et on a dû stopper tout le processus.
Le prix de cette action-là,
ce fut deux années de perdues.
Ça a pris beaucoup de temps.
Mais suite à cette mésaventure-là,
on s’est résolu, forts du constat que pour
faire une montre, il faut du temps,
et pas seulement de l'argent.
Et c’est de là
qu’on a changé de stratégie.
Nous avons créé un groupe de construction.
Et là, on a mis notre savoir-faire
en mouvement.
Lentement, mais sûrement.
Parce qu’en horlogerie, on est face
à des réalités bien spécifiques.
Le bien est l'ennemi du mieux.
Le bien est l’ennemi du mieux,
vous avez bien entendu.
Cela veut dire qu'il ne faut
pas s'arrêter trop vite.
Le parfait existe.
Il y en a qui disent le contraire,
il ne faut pas les croire.
Et il y a une autre réalité :
pour faire le minimum viable product,
il faut aller à 98%.
Parce qu’à 80%, votre mouvement
mécanique, il ne marchera pas.
Un seul 100e de millimètre peut faire
en sorte qu’un composant soit inutilisable
et que des milliers de francs
aient été dépensés pour rien.
Mais bon, je coupe court
à la longue histoire.
Car le 21 mars 2021,
on a enfin pu publier
la première 3D de ce mouvement.
Et depuis, il réjouit des gens
sur toute la planète.
Non seulement les horlogères
et les horlogers,
mais aussi les designers,
et surtout aussi des gens qui sont
simplement des adeptes de l’open source.
C’est quoi le but exactement
de ce mouvement ?
En fait, quand on est horloger,
on n’est pas forcément constructeur.
C’est pourquoi on a fait
ce travail de construction
au sein de l’association openmovement
avec les spécialistes.
Jusqu’à ce jour, on a investi
plus de 6000 heures, bénévolement,
dans ce travail ou dans le projet.
C’est un investissement à l’image
de graines qui ont été
plantées dans un champ.
Ensuite, pour que les graines
puissent pousser,
les membres de l’association
et des mécènes ont mis de l’engrais,
c’est-à-dire du financement.
Financement nécessaire à la fabrication
de tout ce qu’il faut pour 20 prototypes.
Parce qu’ici, on parle d’un projet
open source hardware.
C’est moins commun et bien différent
qu’un projet open source software.
Il faut fabriquer tous les composants.
Voici l'un de nos bénévoles
avec un tas de composants.
Ce tas de composants, il pèse 1,3 gramme.
Il vaut ainsi 30 fois le prix de l’eau.
L’avantage de l’open source, c’est quoi ?
L'avantage, c'est la production en commun.
Grâce à une certaine masse de gens,
on peut produire les composants ensemble.
Les producteurs auront des plus grosses
commandes avec un seul interlocuteur.
Et de l’autre côté, l’individu a
l’avantage d’avoir le prix de gros
sans devoir courir partout.
Le gros avantage est évidemment d'avoir
les fichiers et les plans à disposition.
Les fichiers ont déjà servi
à plusieurs travaux de bachelor.
On a simplement pu les donner.
Il n'y a pas besoin de faire la police.
Et les plans, comme ici, peuvent
servir à faire son propre outillage,
soit pour terminer les pièces,
soit pour les fabriquer soi-même.
Maintenant, vous vous posez
peut-être la question :
« Mais pourquoi un travail d’une telle
ampleur est donné librement
plutôt que de le garder en secret ? »
La réponse est relativement simple :
c’est pour le plaisir de voir
le savoir-faire en mouvement.
Les secrets.
Les secrets de l’horlogerie suisse, on ne
peut pas les donner à toute la planète ?
L’horlogerie suisse est bien
connue pour ses secrets.
L’origine de cela se trouve
dans les concours de chronométrie.
Ils étaient organisés
jusqu’au début des années 1970
dans les observatoires cantonaux,
comme ici celui de Neuchâtel.
Jusque-là, la réputation
d’une marque se mesurait
par la précision de son mouvement.
Il ne fallait pas parler de savoir-faire
horloger entre les horlogers.
Avec l’arrivée du quartz
et de la concurrence étrangère,
ces concours ont été abandonnés.
Ce temps est révolu.
Du coup, je pense à un horloger
retraité qui me dit une fois :
« Je n’ai pas de secret.
Je te donne simplement
ce qu’on m’avait donné. »
Maintenant, à l’ère du tout digital,
où tout le monde a l’heure
sur son téléphone,
pourquoi on fait encore
des montres mécaniques ?
Votre frigo, il se remplit peut-être
grâce à l’intelligence artificielle
il vous commande les mêmes yaourts
que vous avez toujours mangés.
C’est certes bluffant,
Mais finalement le frigo s’ouvre
parce qu’il y a une charnière mécanique.
Notre monde est mécanique.
Et la mécanique horlogère, elle
est particulièrement fascinante.
On a déjà entendu
ce mot plusieurs fois ce soir.
Elle est particulièrement fascinante.
Elle fait briller vos yeux.
Et peut-être encore un petit
peu plus d’avantage ce soir,
parce que vous avez la primeur de voir
le premier prototype qui marche.
Merci pour votre attention.
(Applaudissements)